drink fast as we can swell your drinking
up you can't feel a thing
what do you mean I'm not gonna steal it
mr. Getty your grandson he's been
kidnapped
I asked as another said my boy freak is
a good doctor
I promise yes seventeen million dollars
to release him I don't have any money
get it from your father-in-law he has
all the money in the world
everything has a price these men are
going to take a part of you the great
struggle in life is coming to grips with
what that price is we need to pay the
ransom
people do things to Paul that can't be
undone for any amount of money
how much would you pay to release your
grandson if not 17 million dollars
nothing tell them I'm coming
17,000,000 show brings out a crowd
yes Paul and his mother cooked this up
if Paul ever talk to you about Henry
himself kiddo
who's that Avon mr. chase I thought I
could trust my own blood if she doesn't
pay first the ear thank the hood
bastard you did nothing nobody has ever
been richer than you are at this moment
I have no money to spare what would it
take for you to feel secure more
me
you
you